“Have you heard about all the stuff going
around?”
“I have.”
“Back in the day, your father and I would
handle this and if he was here now, maybe
we’d still handle it.
But he’s not and that’s on you.
So the way I see it, you gotta handle this.”
Bringing the DIY spirit of punk and hardcore
music to indie filmmaking.
How’s it going?
My name is Matt Wells.
I’m an actor and producer on the independent
feature film CROWN & ANCHOR, which will be
released theatrically in the fall of 2018.
CROWN & ANCHOR is an intense family drama
which examines the effects of childhood trauma
and it is scored entirely with punk and hardcore
music.
Bands like GORILLA BISCUITS, YOUTH OF TODAY,
DYS, JOHNNY THUNDERS, X-RAY SPEX (just to
name a few).
I made the movie in my town of St. John’s,
Newfoundland which is where I am right now
hiding from the rain under the trees.
I made the movie with my best friend Michael
Rowe and I met him when I was in a band.
We were in a band together and that’s how
my journey started into filmmaking, it started
with music.
We started to have some success on music television
in Canada.
We were touring with bands like SLAYER and
FISHBONE and D.O.A.
Eventually that journey led me into music
television.
So I all the sudden I went from being a singer
in this independent band to interviewing some
of the bands that I admired.
I became a music and film journalist on music
television and through the years I got to
interview people like Lou Reed and NO DOUBT,
Greta Gerwig and Quentin Tarantino.
But somewhere along that journey I started
to feel I wanted to do something different
which was acting and filmmaking.
And you can imagine what an aspiring actor
and filmmaker can learn from interviewing
people in that world.
I did thousands of interviews and it was always
sort of percolating in my brain.
To be quite honest with you what I learned
as a guy in an independent band, that’s
what gave me the tools to be able to make
a movie.
This sort of D.I.Y.
(do-it-yourself) spirit of punk and hardcore
music, that’s what I lived, that was my
whole life.
We were putting up our own posters, we were
raising money to make albums and music videos,
running it like a small business so we could
go on tour and sustain ourselves to continue
doing something that we loved and that is
exactly how we made this movie and exactly
how we’re approaching the roll out of distribution.
And when you think about it, those worlds
(independent film and independent music) that
punk and hardcore do-it-yourself culture and
spirit, they are very similar and that is
exactly the tools that we used to make CROWN
AND ANCHOR.
What made the production of CROWN AND ANCHOR
unique?
Matt Wells: Our first day on set of CROWN
AND ANCHOR we shot 15 pages which was already
longer than any project our writer/director
Andrew Rowe had worked on in the past which
sort of set the tone for the next 15 days
of filming.
This was Andrew’s first feature and we only
had 15 days to make it happen.
But it created an urgency on set which absolutely
you can see in the performances, you can see
in the direction.
There is something about being under the gun
and knowing that you really don’t have the
option to make a lot of mistakes or second-guess
yourself and that’s really what we did.
And the backstory of CROWN AND ANCHOR is that
we had private investors and we had a strong
script, but it was long.
And everybody told us it was too long at our
budget.
We didn’t want to have to cut it because
of budget.
Because we knew if we cut it at the script
phase, it was going to cut the heart out of
the film.
And Andrew had a distinct vision for this
movie about wanting to really focus on character
development which was going to mean a lot
of long, one-take, no cut scenes.
And Michael and I we connected with that vision
(we believed in it).
So we wanted the ability to cut in the editing
room and not on the page.
So we knew we had to assemble a team who was
amendable to that type of environment.
I mean essentially we had to find people who
wanted a punk rock the heck out of this thing
and that’s what we did.
We found an amazing cast, an amazing crew.
I mean the good thing about having a very
strong script is that it allowed us to attract
very strong actors who had been in the business
for a very long time and without that sort
of experience, never would we be able to make
something like this.
This was a no-frills set.
There were no dressing rooms, no trailers,
it was stripped down.
We had to have a team that were checking their
egos at the door and were cool to work in
that sort of environment and just try to put
all the money on the screen, which is what
we did.
Without this incredible cast and crew it never
would have happened.
So that really, it influenced and it was a
big part of the energy you see on screen.
But not just the environment of production
but also the location.
You know our creative team are spread all
over right now from Toronto to California,
but out home town is St. John’s, Newfoundland
(where I am right now) and there is something
really special about this place.
And if you have a project I highly, highly
recommend you consider coming to make it here
not just because it has a growing and thriving
film community.
Not just because it has an amazing crew here,
really talented actors and not just because
it’s beautiful but because there is an energy
in this place, it’s an island in the middle
of the North Atlantic Ocean.
We are geographically isolated, we are socially
and culturally unique and it also informs
our movie.
And if you don’t believe me how special
it is here just see if you can ask Jason Momoa
I’m sure you can just call him.
The guy is here all the time filming.
It’s not a rare occurrence to see him walking
down the street going to grab a coffee, it’s
a very special place.
And there is something about (not to get into
too much of a history lesson on Newfoundland)
but our ancestors through the years having
to live off the land and the brutal climate,
that sort of helped inform who we are.
And there is a dark, raw beauty to Newfoundland
and there is a strong independence and you
see that in our film as much as you see it
influenced from the words that were on the
script.
What were your biggest challenges?
Matt Wells: So our biggest challenges (I mean
like most independent films) it’s budgetary,
right?
We only had so much money and we had to work
around that.
But honestly our biggest challenges on CROWN
AND ANCHOR came later as we went to market
and they were all self-inflicted wounds.
Like I said everybody told us after reading
the script that they really thought it was
strong but we should not make a movie (as
first time filmmakers) that was running at
two hours, that maybe some of the scenes were
too intense, maybe we shouldn’t score it
with punk and hardcore music because that
might alienate some audiences and that being
in such a beautiful part of the world we should
focus on these exteriors and show more of
the landscape.
But we did the opposite, not because we are
stubborn or we don’t want to collaborate,
it’s because those choices we felt were
true to the characters and true to the story
and that’s what we wanted to do, right?
So we made a movie that runs just under two
hours, no A-list stars, all punk and hardcore
music but these are the things that have allowed
us to get an international sales agent, these
are things that are allowing us to have a
North American theatrical release as an independent
film and it was because it was authentic to
the story and authentic to the characters.
And that’s what we’re doing, right?
As independent filmmakers what we’re trying
to do is chase the authentic stories.
And we knew all these choices were only going
to help the film but again it was because
we knew who our audience was.
Knowing who your audience is is so important
and you know I go back to this idea of the
do-it-yourself punk and hardcore spirit from
that music world that inspired us so much
that we took it to the independent filmmaking
process, the same way that we used that when
we were in a band, the same way we thought
about DIY when we were in production is the
same way we’re rolling out distribution.
You know as independent filmmakers we want
to see our film in theaters, right?
But it’s not always something that we have
access to.
We didn’t want to go straight to DVD, we
didn’t want to go straight to VOD or streaming,
so we’ve taken the same do-it-yourself spirit
and we’ve partnered with independent movie
theaters across North America to do our own
theatrical.
Every independent film journey is going to
be different but this has been our’s.
And it’s because we stuck to our vision,
it’s because we knew our audience and we
were willing to do the work because we believed
in what we were doing.
So I hope you come out to see us when our
film hits your city.
You can check out our website [CrownandAnchorFilm.com]
which is up on the screen here and you know
come out and talk to us.
We’re going to do Q&A’s in some of the
cities afterward with myself, our writer/director
Andrew Rowe, our lead actor Michael Rowe (who
is also a producer on this with me), we want
to talk to you guys and hear your questions
and know what you’re doing and tell you
about filming in Newfoundland.
So that it.
I hope you get to check out CROWN AND ANCHOR.
It’s raining so I’m going to go inside.
Thanks for listening.